c plus plus a statically typed compiled
programming language famous for its
widespread use and software
infrastructure and infamous for its
steep learning curve it was created in
1979 by bjorn strausstrup at at t bell
labs he was inspired by the
object-oriented nature of simula but
needed a language with a high
performance of c and thus c with classes
was born it's designed as a superset of
c which means that virtually any c
program is also a valid c plus plus
program but it also adds zero overhead
abstractions such as object oriented
patterns like polymorphism encapsulation
and inheritance today it's used in a
wide variety of systems with constrained
memory demands like the unreal engine
for aaa video games programs like adobe
after effects that were used to edit
this video databases like mysql and
mongodb embedded systems like the
display on your smart toaster and is
used to implement much of our low-level
infrastructure like language compilers
and virtual machines it's so popular
because it provides low-level memory and
hardware control like c but with high
level abstractions like classes and
smart pointers c plus plus makes it
harder to shoot yourself in the foot but
when you do it'll blow your whole leg
off
to get started install a c plus compiler
like gcc or clang then create a file
ending in cpp include io stream from the
standard library to handle input and
output your code will start executing
from the main function to print hello
world we simply use standard character
output followed by the bitwise shift
left operator and a string literal we
can get rid of this std though by adding
a namespace to the top of the file now
if we want to create a string variable
we can do so by typing it as an array of
characters however if we include string
from the standard library we can use the
string type instead the real game
changer though is the fact that c plus
plus supports object-oriented
programming with classes a class is just
a blueprint for an object inside a class
you can define attributes and methods
that will be private by default or make
them public by adding them under the
public specifier it's also possible to
define methods outside the class
definition using a double colon methods
can also be defined multiple times with
different parameters which is known as
overloading and is a form of
polymorphism in addition we can define
constructors and destructors to run code
when an object is created or destroyed
classes also support inheritance
allowing developers to more efficiently
share logic throughout a program to
instantiate an object type the class
name followed by the name of your object
and optionally any parameters for the
constructor when it comes to memory we
could manage everything manually with
pointers and references however tools
like unique pointer can get the job done
in a way that's easier and safer by
ensuring that only one object can be
allocated to memory now to run your code
open up the terminal and use a tool like
clang plus plus to compile it
this has been c plus in 100 seconds hit
the like button and subscribe if you
want to see more short videos like this
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one